vous n'êtes pas sans ignorer que les
services d'urgence des hôpitaux français
en proie à une crise profonde depuis de
nombreuses années sont aujourd'hui à
bout de souffle il y à 12 ans déjà un
rapport de notre haute assemblée les
décrivez comme le miroir grossissant des
dysfonctionnement de l'ensemble de notre
système de santé
madame la ministre que vous aviez
annoncé dès votre prise de fonction en
de ce problème à bras le corps
mais qu'en est il réellement force est
de constater que la situation s'aggrave
et s'amplifie de jour en jour face à
l'inadéquation entre le nombre de
passages les moyens alloués et la
disponibilité des lits d'aval
malgré les nombreux plans déjà mises en
place ou annoncés on ne peut que
constater leur inefficacité chronique
résultat les personnels de santé d
urgence multiplient les mouvements de
grève sur tout notre territoire
peut-on les blâmer au vu des chiffres et
de la dégradation de leurs conditions de
travail
certainement pas en vingt ans les
urgences ont vu leur fréquentation
doubler nos personnels sont confrontés
chaque jour à la multiplication des
agressions verbales que physiques
car qui dit saturation des services dit
exaspération des patients et épuisement
des personnels soignants qui se sentent
délaissés
nos professionnels de santé réclament à
juste titre davantage de moyens humains
et financiers
alors vous me répondrez certainement que
la loi santé votée à l'assemblée
nationale et en cours de délibération au
sénat pour de la double ambition de
mieux répartir l'accès aux soins et de
libérer les établissements hospitaliers
sous tension mais les mesures annoncées
ne devrait voir le jour qu'en 2022
ce sera déjà trop tard il y a urgence
madame la ministre pour nos urgences
nous ne pouvons plus attendre car nous
parlons ici de notre bien le plus
précieux la santé des français mais
aussi celle de nos personnels de santé
qui n'en peuvent plus tant physiquement
que psychologiquement alors ma question
est simple
quelles mesures d'urgence allez vous
initier pour éviter que d'autres drames
surviennent pour agir enfin et pour
faire face à cet enjeu majeur de santé
publique qui est sous votre
responsabilité qu'on nous réponde la
parole et à madame
la santé les solidarités sur président
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs
monsieur le sénateur sol évidemment vous
avez raison le système est en tension
depuis de nombreuses années et
l'augmentation du nombre de passages aux
urgences n'a fait qu'aggraver les choses
j'ai souhaité accompagner les hôpitaux
cette année avec un dégel particulier
avec un refinancement de 300 millions
dès le mois de mars et 700 millions
d'euros supplémentaires donnés aux
hôpitaux qui d'ailleurs ont réduit leur
déficit cette année ont également réduit
leur d'être toxiques et donc j'essaye
d'accompagner au mieux les hôpitaux qui
sont le plus en difficulté j'ai souhaité
dans les mesures d'urgence que j'ai
annoncé au congrès annuel des
urgentistes que ces crédits nouveaux
soit fléché particulièrement vers des
services d'urgence en réalité la
situation est très variable d'un service
à l'autre et les besoins sont variables
d'un service à l'autre
dans certains cas il manque des médecins
dans d'autres cas plutôt des
professionnels paramédicaux dans
d'autres cas les locaux sont extrêmement
vétustes et trop petit pour accueillir
le flux de malades et donc il faut
pouvoir donner à chaque hôpital à chaque
site
la réponse appropriée j'ai donc demandé
aux agences régionales de santé
d'accompagner les hôpitaux en tension
certains ne le sont pas il ya beaucoup
de services d'urgence en france qui
fonctionne avec moins de quinze mille
passages par an c'est à dire moins de
deux passages par heure et donc il faut
aussi être attentif à ce que les budgets
à y accompagnait des sites les plus en
difficulté c'est ce que nous allons
faire dans les semaines qui viennent
j'annoncerai au delà de la mission
nationale donnée au président du conseil
national des urgences hospitalières le
professeur pierre carli et aux députés
même thomas meunier de repenser notre
système d'urgence pour le refonder
j'annoncerai très concrètement comment
cette offre d'accompagnement va aller
vers les établissements et aller vers
les professionnels
je ne néglige pas leur charge de travail
elle est à la fois physique et nous le
savons vous comme moi parce que vous
êtes un professionnel de santé aussi
elle est aussi émotionnel aux arts aux
aux urgences c'est extrêmement difficile
effectivement de soutenir toutes les
personnes en très grande difficultés
émotionnelles
cela rajoute de la surcharge et je ne
néglige pas ce point dans
l'accompagnement qui leur sera apportée
je vous remercie
merci